um what else oh dude I've been realizing
this so even though I quit smoking my um
you know my jerking off has been kind of
flaring up at night not at the daytime I
noticed my my heavy desires to really
touch out and spray out of my own body
occur around 1:00 a.m. 12:40 1242 1:20 I
almost want to lock my dick away in a
special box because I'll find it and I
will find ways to you know but god I'll
just keep finding ways to touch my own
body until seed flies out of it you know
and it's kind of um it's tough it's
tough when you just do it you know when
you do it too much but but we'll see
we'll see man I'm not gonna feel bad
about it I just wish that I had a bit
more control over it I mean I almost
want to handcuff myself to the [ __ ]
neighbor's door or something but the
crazy thing is I've been noticing when I
do masturbation in my room the
neighbor's dog will start barking and I
don't know if anybody else is a pet
owner I've never been a pet owner you
know I got attacked by a bunch animals
when I was young
two birthdays I got attacked once cats
and I also buy dogs on a different
birthday kind of a group attack they did
but yeah that kind of stuff if you think
that it's not you know it's mmm it's
just kind of alarming to think that the
dog knows I'm doing it so if anybody has
experience with that where animals
behave certain ways around them while
they're experienced and you know full
sexual or self sexual let us know let me
know hit the hot line with that nine
eight five six six four nine five zero
three because I swear to god that thing
and it used to be that I had a neighbor
my neighbors had a cat and if I would
pleasure myself when I would leave the
apartment later the cat would be out
there in front of their apartment and so
so
going on I'm like the dam you know beat
master you know like the Beastmaster he
had all these little ferrets and little
you know Guatemalan [ __ ] steampunks
under his arms and [ __ ] why make the
beat Master do not jerk off and all the
animals show up
that's like damn what's going on cuz
this is I mean I don't I don't think I'm
living in like an a magical apartment
complex but if I'm doing masturbation
I'm doing self Skeet
you know I'm doing that [ __ ] you know
making my little own my you know my own
doing my own Old Faithful over at the
house then there must be something going
on you know I don't know if my if my
what's expelling out of my body is
coming out at a certain you know audible
octave or something if you know the
animals can hear it or if it's I don't
know if I've been eating something that
makes the scent of it real strong or
real primal but you know to that but to
have that cat what that would be on his
doorstep across the way when I would
come out after doing myself and then now
to hear this dog barking whimpering and
look I think the crazy thing is it took
me a while to notice it and finally I
noticed it and I've know every time I
noticed it now
and I'm just thinking what how long was
i doing this without even noticing that
every time I was masturbating that there
was a dog out there you know what dog
was and I didn't even notice that I was
jerking off and there was it sounds of a
you know a big animal and I don't even
care stop you know I guess it just I
don't know to make me feel bad about
myself but it makes me just like what
the [ __ ] man it makes me think I don't
have a lot of skills you know you know
if an animal is jerking off if I'm
jerking off in an animal is you know how
land and stuff through this a regular
apartment of law or you know it just
makes me think I don't have a lot of
skills if I'm not noticing that so I
don't know maybe I need to meditate more
or something but yeah and then it makes
me think well what if ever you know how
far is this happening like how many
animals within like a you know within a
half block radius are there [ __ ]
monkeys swinging around the chandeliers
or birds chirpin you know are the worms
coming up out of the ground like what
the [ __ ] going on when I you know
what's going on so different times man
different times saying I don't want
Santa coming down the tree because it's
a you know embarrassing or down the
chimney can't jerk off without a wolf
coming near you
different times man is it the end of
times well thanks for watching that
video right there that was a beautiful
little segment I think but of course i'm
partisan to myself but you can move on
to another video right now you can check
on this video or on this video that's
two different options and you can also
subscribe to the channel check on a new
video subscribe to the channel check
subscribe check gestures curse car